foreign ministers from a Southeast Asian
Bloc have held an emergency meeting to
discuss the crisis in Myanmar
discussions centered around developing a
new strategy in dealing with myanmar's
military some asean member states as
well as the U.S have called for tougher
action against the military rulers
ministers also discussed an air strike
on Sunday hatching state that killed at
least 60 people
or phones Louis live for us in Kuala
Lumpur so I understand that the foreign
ministers have released a statement what
does it say thorns
right so this is a statement released by
the chair of asean and that's Cambodia
this year now the upshot of this is we
still do not know if asean has a
concrete plan to push for the peace
process in myanmal or if there is there
wasn't much that was revealed in that
statement
um the language used was very soft in
its tone and the sort of words that it
used it's very much in light with in
line with asean's policy of
consensus-style decision making of
non-interference in a member states
domestic affairs just some examples you
know the statement said the situation in
Myanmar remains critical and fragile but
it also went on to say that this was not
because of Any lack of commitment or
effort on asean's part but was due
rather to the complexity of myanmar's
protracted conflicts and that's being
exacerbated by the current political
crisis so as you can see there from the
words that were chosen there is a
there's the the statement there's very
cat they're being very careful not to
call out the Junta and it's used of
disproportionate Force its brutality
against anti-cool opponents now the
foreign ministers did discuss
recommendations that they say will be
used by Asian leaders when they meet in
November to consider but what those
recommendations are we do not know
they've not been revealed in the
statement but if this statement is any
indication I think those who are
expecting asean to take a firmer stance
on Myanmar will be sorely disappointed
it's interesting isn't it there's a
difference between the the tone of the
the statement that you've just been
talking about and yet the fact that they
were prepared to call this emergency
meeting just two weeks before I
scheduled asean summit summit I mean how
critical are they regarding this
situation
well the situation in Yemen I think that
there's the general consensus amongst
many people in the International
Community that the situation in Myanmar
has deteriorated in fact the chair of
asean Cambodia just two days before this
meeting issued a statement saying the
group I.E asean is Gravely concerned
about the escalation of violence in
Myanmar and of course this meeting is
taking place just days after there was
an airstrike in kachin state where
dozens of people were killed also on
Tuesday itself the UN special Envoy on
Myanmar who had visited the country in
August and met Junta Chief minonglang
told a U.N committee that the human
rights political and humanitarian crisis
in Myanmar is deepening and that this is
taking a quote catastrophic toll on the
people of Myanmar she said more than 13
million people do not have enough to eat
more than one million people have
already been displaced and the military
continues its use of disproportionate
force of violence against civil million
population including burning and sacking
houses and buildings launching aerial
bombardments conducting arbitrary
arrests torture and detention centers
U.N special repertoire on human rights
for Myanmar said that the International
Community has failed the people of
Myanmar that's the situation you have in
the country at the moment then the
junta's stand is that it is merely doing
things to restore order and it has
described those who fight against it as
terrorists with whom it will not engage
in negotiations so this meeting really
was about trying to find a way out of
the situation out of the crisis in
Myanmar but we're getting very little
indication of just one what what stands
or what what steps asean is going to
take in that regard Florence thank you
very much indeed Florence to be talking
to us from Kuala Lumpur